o atual acho que uma coisa em casa hoje
a procuração de tubo por onde chega uma
encomenda dos estados unidos vem aí o
botão então do youtube botão de londres
sobe segundo botão do milhão de
inscritos eu tô super ansioso província
joão sousa saiu desta quadra grande
beijo só uma coisa é aquela partida é
agora deus meu deus meu deus mateus 21
dias até ser a pessoa que enviou o
placar
suzanne pote que teve e mesmo assim não
dela
hoje o uol
como é que uma coisa tão bonita ou soft
gigante
[Música]
aqui é muito pesado mesmo porque isso
significa trabalhar até agora e tudo que
fizeram por mim
acompanharam até agora estão aqui dentro
eu tenho certeza que vocês estão aqui
dentro da série eu vou encontrar o
melhor espaço não vai encontrar a melhor
casa o melhor da minha mãe porque
colocou a capital só crianças mas agora
eu não pude expressar essa oportunidade
eu não sei só saíram atrás mas que eram
muito longos do pêlo de qualidade é um
aspecto a uma espécie é basicamente o
que encontrei para incluir na bica de
pedra dos kills portanto ficamos aqui eu
eu acho que o proape tal no mínimo no
estúdio eu vi lá muitos comentários tipo
do mesmo
os vídeos vão estar me vão apoiar meu
isso é muito bom e se emociona muito
mesmo ler estes comentários
eu não sei o que eu vou dizer mas eu não
sei vocês são os réus só isso mas
obviamente isso obrigado por tudo
independentemente de fazer vigília ok
o juiz teve um pouco boston um pouco
mais trabalhados obrigado por estarem
sempre estimulado e por me apoiarem
protestar em mim por e e principalmente
como colocarem onde estou eu não tenho
visualizações por mim eu não tenho o que
eu tenho um experimento não tem uma
qualidade de vida melhor só por mim eu
devo isto graças a vocês
e aqui está a prova está que não é nada
meu isso aqui é tudo voz esta porta é
voto e expressão clichê
ai meu deus não é dado foram responderam
estudo portanto o meu profundo e sincero
obrigado mesmo por isso tudo e eu tenho
certeza que agora as coisas vão ficar
muito melhor eu vou arranjar a porcaria
de uma casa ou um estúdio o que quer que
seja
eu vou tratar muito mas tudo vai bem bom
ter a noção da felicidade
vocês vão ver os vídeos eu passei bons e
ruins porque eu vou gravar muito quando
eu tive como inscrito ontem assinado eu
fui você mesmo formato tentar um
lançamento da nintendo suíte foi lá por
casa eu fui por divertir mesmo tê la
como posso ser eu gravei algumas imagens
4chan fiquem com imagem de bom que
aconteceu por lá e não se pode expor
tanto o jovem se você não viu e irei só
muito obrigado mesmo por todo o apoio e
fica mais fácil estado de espírito
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o lançamento
[Música]
para
tchau